hello freak so I mean I don't
want me to just jump right into this but
it kind of freaked me out that your you
have involvement in pro wrestling do you
own the NWA yeah I bought the National
Wrestling Alliance the oldest brand in
the world I was working for TNA you know
I was president for a hot second then I
got fired and you were president of TNA
yeah yeah that's a crazy story I don't
know how much you want to get into that
well you know Dixie Carter owned a TNA I
knew her through the years I used to go
to show stuff like that and and at some
point they approached me about investing
I said no then they offered me a job I
started working for the company then
they would they here start having money
problem to start putting money in and
through the contrivance of all that then
I started getting more power in the
company and putting in more money so
then it became like well if I'm gonna
put in all this money and I'm gonna have
all this power I want to run the show
they basically said that was cool and
then the minute I had the spot it was
like Game of Thrones they all started
kill me off and and then you know
wrestling's weird because you have this
weird mix of reality and fantasy and
it's hard sometimes to know where one
thing and the fans get into both the
behind the scenes and the fantasy so no
one's quite sure sometimes where the
blur is and yeah I got pretty crazy for
a while there's a lawsuit a real lawsuit
yeah right i sued I sued and this is a
quick funny thing people continually
write that I lost the law so I never
lost the lawsuit I lost one of the
motions which led to them me negotiating
and we we said a lot of court but the
judge the contract that they signed that
would have allowed me to take over the
company under the under the motion that
I had filed the judge basically
dismissed my motion because the contract
they had signed with me was illegal
under Tennessee law even though a
Tennessee lawyer had negotiated on the
company's behalf and signed it whoa that
sounds like some double-cross wrestling
type yeah yeah so it'd be like if you
did a contract with me and then I sued
you and then the judge says well even
though Joe had a California lawyer sign
it's illegal under California law so
therefore the contracts meaningless
it was bizarre how does one go from
Smashing Pumpkins pro-wrestling and then
go so deep that you're like an owner ya
know it's it's pretty wild
unexpected for a lot of people right
yeah yeah I know I get that a lot and
I've learned actually I've actually
learned over time it's just best to keep
the world separate because the music
fans don't want to hear anything about
the rest of them I mean they just don't
they just they get they that I'm a bit
goofy but they just don't want to hear
about the wrestling thing they asked
they asked the world's to be kept
separate did they ever get mad at you oh
yeah yeah you know and you can
appreciate that it kills the gimmick yes
they want me to be this goth vampire guy
or whatever and then it's like hemant
and then there's pro wrestling it's just
it just totally kills the gimmick it's
really funny though I think it's awesome
yeah I love when people just get into
what they like well that's something I
appreciate about you you know what I
mean like I've watched where you guys go
deep dives and MMA and other things it's
like I think it's cool to have multiple
interests I it's the renaissance man
thing yeah well I think for for some
reason people shy away from that because
they think folks are gonna be confused
I don't care yeah good for you that's
awesome yeah
now I growing up in Chicago there was a
really rich wrestling history in Chicago
growing up I might my great grandmother
watch wrestling I mean it was like I
grew up in the at four years old I'm
watching dick the bruiser on television
and this is also the era of hockey
fights and roller derby Oh Road there B
so we'd watch hockey Pro Wrestling and
you know it was in the family yeah and
then later I found out that my other
great-grandmother also watch wrestling
so both sides of the family both great
grandmothers watching wrestling so it's
just in the blood I guess we like that
we like the carny of it all well I'm
always amazed at roller derby never made
like a serious comeback they tried they
kind of did the the you know the
tattooed girls roller derby hipstery
type of thing it had a moment there well
I know I had a friend who was into it
and she you know was that type I just I
thought well that seems like something
that would catch on today yeah they
transitioned from like roller derby to
Suicide Girls yeah get a little hotter
yeah girl you could be thick and be a
roller derby girl you could you could
eat all the carbs you like the roller
be back in the day was huge yeah I mean
they were doing like packed arenas and
stuff that's crazy well it's fun to
watch it's pretty wild yeah you seem go
after each other and skating around it's
pretty aggressive it's fun it's fun it's
like racing plus fighting and yeah hip
checking each other like you know it's
early days memory but I remember
thinking you know so there's something
sort of hot about the whole thing yes I
think especially in Chicago the women's
roller derby was bigger than the men's
so that says something yeah I didn't
even know there was men's roller derby
like thinking of men's roller derby I'm
completely drawn a blank it just I
always associate it with like tough
women yeah yeah that's what I'm saying I
think the women's thing actually had
some sort of staying power where the
men's I think it didn't have the same
allure maybe yeah yeah I guess you're my
age remember killer Kowalski course yeah
yeah yeah I remember watching that when
I was a kid in Boston watching it on the
on regular TV you know that those guys
were great I mean it's a golden age it's
like anything you can go back and sort
of romanticize it and I think that's
part of what we're trying to do is
that's the cool thing about the NWO is
we actually possess that history mm-hmm
and and so our job is to sort of update
it you know to bring it to bring that
tough-guy thing back into the modern
world in a way that sort of doesn't
insult the audience's intelligence so
the NWA is that older than the WWE 1948
is the NWA whoa yeah and the cool thing
about the NWA s history was you had all
these rival promoters including the
McMahons in the Northeast that
eventually sort of formed a kind of
ad-hoc association to create a better
business in essence get everybody on the
same page and what they would do is they
named one champ and the champ would
rotate through the different territories
come in and take on the whoever was the
local guy they build up the local guy
and then a guy like Ric Flair would come
in and beat the local guy and it would
always be like a bit of a scrum and then
he'd come back for a second there would
be a cage match and then Ric Flair would
move on to the next territory and that's
how those guys rotate around then
everybody made more money Wow
and then the government got involved at
different points because there was
collusion there you go there's there's
Ric Flair with our belt actually I
follow him on Instagram yeah yeah I mean
risk Rick's
in dusty flat dusty roads or our you
know the probably the two most prominent
chance that the NWA had so just to be
the owner of that history is like so
humbling for me as a fan it's like wow
that is so cool
yeah that's pretty wild actually
[Applause]
[Music]